[Music]
hey guys welcome to another episode
about little boys and today we are taste
testing survival foods so I called up my
friends at camping survival calm and as
something they could send me some
products to taste tested and sure enough
they did a great job and they said it's
a whole bunch of stuff we have got some
really cool things like I have a pizza a
slice of pizza right here pepperoni
pizza I've got a can of pork brains
dehydrated cod some whipped cream cheese
in a can
energy bars and cheesecake so we're to
go through and try this all guys you
excited yeah alright guys so first off
let's try these energy bars here these
are basically pure calories they don't
require any cooking just pull them out
and eat up find your shelf life on these
things that there's three different
companies here represented we've got
made a mainstay and we've got a date Rex
they each have different flavors and
slightly different textures so we're
gonna we're gonna test those out so we
try to the mainstay emergency rations
first let's check this out here a big
cookie kind of a just a big break yeah
it's like sawdust where they've added a
lot of flavors to it yeah it's like I
could definitely eat this for a meal
it's not disgusting but it's not lovely
either yeah I'm at dry cooking no really
dry cookie so once everyone's verdict on
the midday food rations
alright so Nathan liked it he thought it
was like a cookie I thought it was man
it was okay I could eat it but didn't
love it Tommy disliked it and mom
thought it was okay I mean I didn't like
it
better have a lot of water handy because
even just that little piece like made me
super like oh I need water so they're
not a good very very dry
all right now we're going to try the
mainstay food bars and see what they're
like this comes in like three cubes kind
of the same color same texture as the
other ones
alright you guys want to test these out
here
yeah there's four of us here it'd be
they're really really similar to the
other ones but the made a ones tastes a
little like Apple ish cinnamon ish
apples in yellow apple cinnamon and
these ones taste a little bit like
cookie dough not as sweet
not as sweet though not as sweet I mean
I don't think anyone would rave over
these but everyone's eating it you know
the kids are eating it yeah I get a
little bitter you know those Maine state
bars are actually growing on me I kind
of cut them now you know yeah all right
guys what's everyone's verdict on the
main stage survival bars there you go I
needed whole juice up so Nathan loved it
I gave it a solid not bad Tommy said I
liked it and Bobby said better than okay
so across the board everyone likes them
a little bit better you do they got to
tell you this is a big deal because if
we're gonna prepare survival food for
our family the kids have to eat it you
know that's the thing you know we have
enough trouble getting your kids to eat
normal foods so party words next I'm
gonna try the date Rex or dot Rex
survival bars we just open Oh
easy oh these look different oh look
they're individually wrapped - that's
that's actually really convenient look
at this they're like little little
bricks of spam okay seems like there's
more of it - they're all of these
they'll individually wrapped little
bricks totally looks like spam or
scrapple very hard well there's a piece
for you these for you buddy yeah this
one tastes more like a cracker and less
like a cookie you know it doesn't taste
as sweet but it's good on the detracts
food rations our opinion is all right
so Nathan gave it scribbly marks and he
liked it though he hasn't been very
articulate about it I said tough call I
like the flavor of the mainstay ones
better but only slightly but these come
individually wrapped it's a tough call
Tommy
seems to have liked it a lot and drew a
beautiful picture of a flying monkey now
did you like these ones the most or did
you like the other ones better because
they're great for building that good you
liked even better than okay even a
little better than okay it's very
convenient that they're individually
wrapped and it's kept Tommy busy and the
flavor was flavor was fine and actually
because it wasn't quite as sweet it
might be better for eating it long-term
yeah yeah it's a little bit more of a
meal and less of a candy or something I
was thinking I'd like to put peanut
butter on it yeah I could see that I
could see that oh you keep mixing into a
stew or something or cooking with it
yeah so Nations over here chewing on the
main stage he's got a sweet tooth down
boy yeah you got 1,200 calories there in
one pudgy little hand baby yeah oh you
play with that a lot
we've gone from bare minimal survivalist
foods to a little bit of a luxury item
here we've got a thing of Begich cheese
here it's an Australian canned cheese
cheese is obviously pretty hard to get
in a survivalist situation so this can
be a very much a luxury he
but uh is it gonna be awesome or is it
gonna be a gun let's find out all right
so that's what it looks like inside it's
just soft white cheese but let's see if
it pays any good
who likes cheese that me and Tommy have
actually eaten this before when we did
our zombie apocalypse fishing video
great video I'll put a link in the
description check it out Mike from one
rod and one reel gets eaten by zombies
it's pretty cool do you guys want some
more yeah okay you got some more all
right
you know this tastes a lot like laughing
cow cheese if you're here in the states
I mean it's it's the same thing it's
kind of a soft spreadable cheese so you
could put this on crackers or something
don't put your finger in there hold on
that guy wrote I like cheese crackers
you like it yeah so must I started
running into the wall Nathan did you
like the cheese
Gavin Meghan and I I went to the bunch
yeah I thought that was totally legit
and I'm gonna actually eat it in the
nonsurvival situation it was good this
is one of the things that I'm most
excited to check out this is a pizza
it's got a three year shelf life no
cooking required you just heat it up and
eat it right out of the package just
want to try this all right let's do
pizza we're gonna heat this up by just
submerging the pack in some hot water
here just to heat it up just give it a
few minutes and see what happens you
guys ready to try some pizza and we're
just gonna fish this out of here
well that smells legit
that is awesome yeah what kind of looks
and smells like the pizza used to get at
school cafeterias but I mean it looks
legit just straight out of the bag look
at that
everyone's gonna get a piece what do you
think maybe the toppings are kind of
weak but the breads actually really good
Freddy's I mean for just heating it up
that's this isn't just survival this is
like I think these can be our little
boys just decided to draw zombies and
are no longer drawing their opinion so
we're gonna just for go with the
drawings and I'm gonna say the pizza was
the two thumbs up
what do you think yeah sure two thumbs
up sure I would take that camping I
would I think that's legitimate food all
right guys we're gonna try another one
of these meals in a bag here this is a
bacon sandwich so we're gonna go throw
it in the hot water get it heated up
nice and warm we've got the bacon
sandwich here there we go like a little
pizza pocket sandwich bacon and little
bread there we go try a bacon sandwich
it's a little warm still oh wait it's
not the greatest bacon in the world but
it's bacon wrapped in bread heaven
brings pretty good you got the bread
down so yummy hey do you like your bacon
sandwich who like the bacon sandwich
more than the pizza whoa who liked the
pizza more than the bacon sandwich mmm
okay so Nathan like both more than the
other one equally and you like the pizza
best yeah okay I like the bacon sandwich
best
he's best cheese the can of cheese is
better than all of them
and Nathan just loves everything's
alright girls gonna try this fully
cooked beef wrap with seasoned Mexican
style spices gonna heat it up throwing
the boiling water to see what that
tastes like
that means now just pickin cheese out of
the can okay stop stop using your
fingers come on man oh is like a
tortilla to the Mexican style beef wrap
looks like there's two of them in here
[Music]
alright so that's what it looks like
inside spiciness is good it's not spicy
at all if you're into eating like
serious Mexican food you'd laugh at this
is it not spicy it's just seasoned you
know is all it is but yeah but if you
want to kick it up it's really easy to
throw some Tabasco sauce and there's
some hot sauce that keeps really well
who liked the tortilla thing you spit it
out into the mystery spicy between the
bacon sandwich the pizza and the
tortilla which do you like the best
Oh actually I almost like better but not
for long term even I think this would
mix it up a little bit but if I had to
give something for a week I would
probably choose the pizza thank you
right I like the flavor of this but I'd
rather have like the bacon sandwich of
Oz you eat like 10 of them now he's
gonna live on pizza and bacon sandwiches
for a week
here is your Taco Tuesday folks that's
what you need to do this is Taco Tuesday
next we're gonna try a very retro
survival food pilot bread crackers
okay these are kind of like hardtack
or naval biscuits or a lot of things
that were used for rations for a long
time
and so let's visit go they just
basically an unleavened bread in the
shape of a cracker see what we got here
all right basic okay here you go here's
a bit for you tell me one a cracker yeah
if you took a saltine cracker and made
it really thick and chunky and took away
all the extra salt yeah that's pretty
much what I did need some cheese who
wants to do their cracker yeah that's
the thing is a cavities and candies
pilot bread crackers you got a meal I
mean I could I could sit down in a pinch
fill my belly with that well you know
what we need to try next guy's pork
brains cuz we can't eat pork brains
without crackers the crackers pork
brains go hand-in-hand and it comes with
milk gravy are you excited to you mmm
the freshness seal is broken oh yeah you
know what we need a bowl to dump this
bit that looks exactly like
[Music]
Hey Baby you wanna try some of this it
looks like cat food
I don't even I don't want to eat it
either
I mean oh come on guys it's pork brains
get myself a pilot cracker here it's
slip you got my cheese cheese all right
nice big thing of pork I really should
check to make sure this is pre cause a
little bit of pork brains on pilot
cracker let's give it a go that actually
tastes like mushed up Vienna sausages to
be perfectly honest pretty much was like
of course nobody my family will touch it
so I'd rather get a can of Vienna
sausages I think so what did you think
of the pilot crackers mom got a smiley
face
she liked the crackers and cheese Tommy
drunk drew a zombie and also likes the
crackers and Nathan drew a zombie with
my help that says crackers not brains
and I too drew drawings that says I love
crackers I think it's unanimous everyone
liked the pilot crackers now as the only
person who tried the brains brains not
so good see I grew an unhappy face with
my zombie he's got a pilot cracker in
brains they were okay but it's hard to
get over the fact that it's pork brains
and milk gravy it's it tastes better
than it sounds whoa it was a little
rough very there's like an iron
aftertaste next we're gonna try
dehydrated cod fillets I'm really
excited to try these out these are
actually fish fillets in the can
dehydrated they also sold beef steak and
pork chops that are dehydrated as well
this is either gonna be the awesomest
thing I've ever seen or it's gonna be a
complete bomb but we're swinging for the
fences here on this this is dehydrated
and so you have to reconstitute the me
and you
just add some water and off to the races
you have to soak it for a little bit so
I'm gonna go and start preparing this so
we can try it out let's see oh that
definitely smells like fish huh look at
that
it's crazy if it ticking up the cod you
got a smell is it that's a pungent smell
isn't it
hey here feel this feel this this is a
crazy light it's like a feather is
there's really nothin to it
yeah smelly feather this smelly is
really better look at that it is just
packed in there there is a lot of flay's
in here here I'm going to go ahead and
try to reconstitute this look at that
just floats like a cork all right so I'm
gonna take this little plate here and
we're gonna put it on top to try to sink
that down the Cod's been soaking for an
hour and the cans that that's how long
it took to reconstitute it so let's see
oh it's still floating a lot
alright there is a piece of
reconstituted cod and doesn't quite feel
like fresh fish meat but close it feels
very fragile little spongy and a strong
smell to it let's try it battering this
and fry it or make little fish and chips
here maybe all right we got a card
batter let's fry it up
[Music]
feels more natural now that it's all
cooked yeah looks really good
well it's proofs in the pudding let's
hope we go let's let's crack it open and
see what it looks like inside wow that
looks like real fish man at least by
side it's hard to tell that I was ever
dehydrated look at that mom do you want
try some there's something about it it
is a little off but the fish is a little
rubbery and it doesn't taste like fresh
meat tastes like old fish you know
[Music]
smells strong it is not the best if you
really love fish you might be okay with
this but if you if you're not a fish fan
this will not jive with you strong
strong it smells strong yeah I really I
really want to try the beef the
dehydrated beef steak and then would be
higher in Portugal II want to try that
now well guys we've got only two things
left you guys want to try the strawberry
cheesecake and the whipped cream you
guys ready for that let's do it
whoa smell this well that smells good
that smell good that smell good we're
gonna pour this in here it's some cold
water yeah I'm gonna I should have put
this in on I should have put this in the
pool
it's like pig brain but it smells a lot
better doesn't it
I should have dumped this out dead out
of the water would have gone a lot
better I whipped it for two minutes and
I leveled it out now we're just gonna
kind of let it set up for a few minutes
here you strawberry you like it yeah so
all the cheesecake is sitting up I'm
gonna go ahead and try to make some of
this spiffy whip here to go on top and
this says you take one cup of spiffy
whip and mix it with one cup ice water
beat it at high speeds for three to five
minutes and tell peaks form and then
serve immediately all right now this 50
whip is a little bit of a cheat you know
if you're in a survival situation you're
not gonna have ice water unless it's
winter time and you're not gonna have a
KitchenAid probably but you can actually
beat this by hand I'm just super lazy so
I'm gonna try it first with the mixer
but uh well look it's actually working
just kind of like did nothing all of a
sudden they went whippy yeah take a
little take a little lick what do you
think bud means close to marshmallow
cool taste like marshmallow oh that was
good tastes like marshmallows a little
bit yeah kinda loader this whipped cream
but here yeah that is so fluffy looking
yeah it kind of looks like marshmallows
well I think you guys are liking that
alright your ody dig in yeah let's go
ahead Oh
more like pudding but it's weird not
being cold room temperature it says kind
of fight so you see the texture it's
just kind of like a thick pudding with
graham cracker sprinkles and the the
whipped cream holds up really well who
liked the cheesecake raise your hand if
you like the cheesecake
yeah I mean it's not the best dessert
ever but it's kind of cool it's gonna be
it is it instant pudding who like the
whipped cream well yeah like this part I
really dig this this is actually really
good I can't eat lots of uses for that
so yeah not bad not bad at all did
better than the car well guys I thought
this was loads of fun there was some
really awesome foods here there was some
hits there was some misses but I'm gonna
honestly say most of it was really good
and I'm really surprised at what they
can do with food technology nowadays so
definitely check out camping survival
dot-com I'll put a link in the
description to all these different
products they sell and thanks for
watching guys and we hope you enjoyed
this if you want to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to
mmm
you gonna whip cream all over your face